From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
My name is Joe Maneye of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm in North Charleston, South Carolina with John Bishop, our videographer on Thursday, June the 9th, 2011.
We are here to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Our interview today will be conducted by Professor Kerry Taylor of this Department of History at the Citadel here in Charleston, and we're delighted to have Kerry with us to contribute.
We are here today to interview Mr. William Sumders, and with that I think, Kerry, I will turn it over to you. Thank you.
Mr. Sumders, to start us out, could you tell us where and when you were born?
I was born in New York City in 1935. I was sent to Johns Island when I was 18 months old on a train with a tag to be picked up on Johns Street from the train station where my grandfather picked me up.
You sent from New York City to Charleston to be with your grandparent?
My grandparent's on Johns Island. Charleston, this is where the train went. My mother was from Johns Island, she moved to New York, and that's where I was born.
Now did you have brothers and sisters? Come a little bit more about that.
At that point, I guess I had three brothers and sisters. Later on I had another brother that was born.
My brothers and sisters was on Johns Island when I came. They were living with their father and grandfather. The other side of the family.
But you were raised by your grandparent?
My mother's father and mother.
Tell me a little bit about Johns Island in the 1930s and the 1940s. What kind of a place was it like to grow up?
I think Dr. Carey looking at it now is so different from looking at it then because at that time it was not all that nice of place now.
It seems to be a paradise compared to a long time ago.
But we ate everything from the river, from the world to grow everything. And everybody had access to the land.
You go to the river, you go to the woods, hunt, there were barriers and so many things grew wild nuts.
And everything was just so good as I looked back over. It was a good place to grow wild.
Now tell me your grandparents, your grandfather was a farmer?
Yeah, he was a farmer. But he died when I was seven. He died in 1943.
So I was just eight years old when he died. But he was a farmer. He was really an unusual fellow.
He used to survey land, had no formal education. But he used to survey land for other people.
And he had something made like an A. And he could wind that around every time he'd do it five or six times. That's an acre.
And we got trees, he was playing trees at those places. And those things are still there today. He was really good.
We just beginning to get black civil in the years now. For a long time we had none. But coming from Africa, they had their own things.
And John Psyll, this was predominantly an African-American community that you grew up in?
Yes, you know, on John's Island, it's probably been at that point about 75-80% African-American.
And one of the things that my grandparents and all the elders would tell young blacks is that you can do anything that you want to.
But you've got to stay away from white men because you can't get in trouble. You can't win no matter what you do.
You can't win and be understood that. So there were very little conflict within those times.
You know, I talked a little bit earlier. It was so much fun. You made your own toys. You used to have cans that you could hold in and roll and make noise like motors and all that stuff.
And we used to work from what they call from kindergarten, from the time you're can seen them until you can't see at night.
We had no fat people because everybody worked. Ain't a whole lot of food, but everybody worked very physically.
You know, focused to work and tell somebody to pass out.
From what age would you begin to come to Charleston or what would bring you to Charleston as a young person?
God, when I first got, yes, I really came to Charleston. It's that I got burned. I was supposed to come to Charleston to buy some shoes.
My brother was older than me. So I never got any new clothes. Everything I got was what he had.
And then God made it that my feet grew bigger than his. They had to send me the charts and the bison. Use shoes. You know, nobody got new shoes.
There was a place that used to get old shoes and they would redo it. And I stood before a fire and got my leg on fire burned myself up.
I was pretty bad and they had to take me to the doctor. That's how it came to Charleston. I had that first time.
How did you relate? I was in the winter time and everybody used to have fire by the road waiting to get a ride on a truck of bus that was coming by.
And I stood too close to the fire and it caught my plans on fire and it burned me pretty bad. Got some bad scars from that.
You eventually came to Charleston for high school? Well, that was a long time. I came to Charleston many times before that because we had a farm.
And then we started bringing stuff to the market itself. I used to even sell something called Lightwood and you know what Lightwood was.
But it's the inner side of a pine tree that died and you cut it up and you use it to start fire.
It was like what they call spinoffs now but you can light it and it has like oil in it. And I used to cut that and use the sandals for 10 cents a bunch.
And I used to bring it to Charleston 10-15 bunch of it. I had a dollar and 20 cents.
I used to also been chicken and we were talking early. Things has changed so much. My grandmother will give me two chickens to bring to the market.
And I would get five dollars for those two chickens. You can imagine that was very, very expensive. Eggs was dollar and something at that.
Nobody that grew chicken ate chicken. You know, we brought the chicken to the market. You sold it and then the people that bought it would give you back the heart, deliver and all of those stuff.
And then that goes back and my grandparents and would make a real stew out of that with black pepper and onion and garlic.
And they made it so good that we could make each seven to bad health. I mean, it was really, really good stuff.
Now I know that Esau Jenkins was someone who you know, who you have a long history with and has had a big impact on your life.
Do you remember how old you were when you met Esau Jenkins under what circumstance?
Well, he was the son of school superintendent and the teacher and when the class is. So I knew him from the time I started going to church five, six years old.
And he was also always involved in the politics of things. Our school didn't have any, you know, no lights or anything.
And he had to contract to bring wood to the school where we used to catch fire and weapons and stuff like that.
And also, and with the, excuse me, the bus that when kids got a chance to go to Burke School, because we couldn't go to the White High School on John's Island, he ended with a contract to bring down kids over to this school.
But Esau did so many amazing things because he was a businessman. He ran for the Constituent School Board on John's Island in 1956.
They've never been another election hell from 56 to 70. They just stopped having election. That was one of the most, I'm still trying to find today how you stop having election in America.
But they did. And all they did is anytime somebody wanted off, they had disappointed a new person, a new white male, but it just went on.
To keep these off the family.
Well, no, but to keep blacks and off the board after I did some studies in this, been in the last few years, they stopped having election all over Charleston County, because they were afraid at that point that blacks were going to get elected to school board.
And when Stokeley Carmichael and some of them, and we skipping some stuff, or when Stokeley Carmichael came to John's Island in 1967, we had to start making decisions that we wanted some blacks on the school board in District 9.
And so what we did, we told them we wanted three people on the board. We gave them the names of those three people. And we said, you don't have to do it, then we're going to hold on the election.
And we set it up, we're going to hold on the black election, we have a black school board, and we have a white school board.
So what they did to avoid that, they appointed one person that we wanted, and they appointed Esau Jenkins to that board. From 56, this was 68. So they appointed him.
And they appointed him for one reason that Esau Jenkins and I was getting along pretty bad at that point. And that's what the reason they appointed Esau was one of the founders of SCLC with Dr. King, Dr. King stayed on John's Island with us.
My wife did the cooking, all that stuff. But I was a part of Stokeley Carmichael and the student on Valorant, like Malcolm X. So those two group was not mixing. And they appointed Esau, so Esau and I can have a fight.
Yeah. What were the kinds of things that began to contribute to your political sensibilities as a young person?
Well, I caught so much hill as a young person and having some ambition. My grandmother gave me, I think, back in probably 49, a couple of acres of land that I could plant for myself.
And I was catching the bus trying to get them after graduating from elementary school and then went to the ninth grade and trying to do farm.
And I couldn't even come up with the money to buy lunch and stuff like that. And the kids in Charleston teased us so much the way that we dressed, the way that we talked.
I mean, we were just really outcasts at this high school. And the second year, they had a sophomore, a group of us got together and decided to volunteer for the Army.
And I was 16 at that time, but they really didn't care like they don't today. They let my age be 18 and I was able to go into the military.
I went to Fort Jackson and then it was one of the most amazing things to California down the plane. And went to Hawaii, took my basic training in Hawaii.
And only volunteers could go there. And my suffering, after I looked back at it, I suffered more racism in the United States Army than I've suffered any place.
In my life before or after in a distance. Well, let's go for your barracks in Hawaii. And we left right from there, went straight to Korea, no vacation, no nothing.
Went straight to war. And they took us in on ILST where they dropped the front of it in the water where you run up on the beach with guns and bare nets and stuff like that.
And that's one of the scariest things. And you and I were talking earlier, that's still having flashback with some of that stuff. But were you about three miles away from fighting anybody? Go ahead.
You confronted more racism in Hawaii than you had encountered in John's Island or in Charleston.
How why and the military and even in Korea, racism was real, real bad in Korea. And Hawaii and I just realized later on, it was right after 1951, they had just really integrated the Army.
There were four blacks in our company, one Hispanic, one Indian. And we were the really, and I didn't realize until many years later that all of these people, poor white men, who also had a lot of problems.
And the only place that they could invent any of those problems was on people like me. So they had their own problem reason. And we had a lot of fights with that.
What kinds of people do you remember particular instances?
I had physical fights and a guy would beat me. But my grandmother, a bad temper. I get real mad. I don't give up. So I don't stop when people say to stop. So I ain't a being the one getting in trouble.
But they did so many things to the blacks. I had one guy, one of my best friends who died recently. They made him dig a six by six by six hole.
And then they saw him drop a dime and then they can close it up. You know, those things, they're trying to stop.
And it's a lot of it coming back to me more and more knowledge is having a lot of flags back with that. Even in Korea and the war, I mean, this guy might first sergeant who I didn't know on the front line.
We just fought for two days. And I was going up the hill on top. And he said to your black center, if you come up here, I blew your brains out. And he had a 45 on me.
And I decided at the point I was carrying my rifle was in the hole. I was going to roll and get my gun. You know, like you saw some of the movies. And I said, that hole, that 45 blow, whole straight through you.
Because I seen 45 sharp people going to throw a hole back out. I went back to my hole and stayed there. When it was time for us to leave, he sent for me and said that I had made me leave the whole company out.
And of course, being in front, you get killed first. So he makes sure that that was in front going out. Those kinds of stuff. So there's a lot of stuff that we can lie about because if you don't, you cry about it.
So, but the racism is just really heavy. Coming back, even in the California, when we got back as heroes, because I got wounded and believe it, they're in California.
They start calling out to white soldiers name. And then they call the black soldiers. I never understood that until we got on. But black and white soldiers couldn't ride in the same train coach across America.
So you had to ride in separate coaches. And I got into Fort Jackson. I was in the hospital for four months, but for my wound. So I got paid, got about $500, which was a monumental amount of money back in those days.
And we went into Columbia, South Carolina. And I ran it to the Greyhound bus station. My buddy kept it back. And I ran it to the Greyhound bus station. And the cop came to me with his gun, pushed down.
He said, boy, what's wrong with you? You know you don't belong in here. And I never knew that I didn't belong in the Greyhound bus station.
I never left Benoffa, John's Island to go through that kind of segregation. And I said, no, I didn't know I didn't belong here. We do I belong.
And he showed me the back of the bus station where black sport tickets outside. And when the bus comes, white loaded in the bus. And he see the left in the back.
And we had access to those things. And my bitterness really began that time really hard. I just didn't understand it. And I used to call all whites racist at that point.
Because he's some guy that I was with for a year. And yet no, no, when I'm saying, we're building, let me get the ticket for you. Or let him get this ticket. Nobody's ever won. I know all of my white friends just dropped it here. And nobody said anything.
So it became self-curilinians upon returning. Yeah. I got everything with it. You know, only place that I've ever really been an American was basically in Hawaii, a little bit there and Korea and in Japan. I've never been an American in America.
I've always been a second class citizen in America.
Tell me about your, your, your four one of your, your injury. Well, I stepped on a, a, a booby trap on the God December 26, 1951. I'll never go away. And I wasn't really all thing because I was assistant squad leader. And the snow was almost too fee deep.
And the rule was everybody walking the same, the squad leader walks there and everybody 14 men walk right in that same track. And I was the last man in the thing and it went off on me.
It's really a good, that's the kind of luck I practice most of my life. And you know, it hit me and I went up, it hit my M1 rifle and busted and high off. And then it was what, it's what you call a booby trap trip flare.
And then it went way up about 50 feet up in the air and lit up. And that's how they used to shoot people because they would show you where you are. And I laid, I knew I lost my leg and I felt it was there.
And some of the soldiers said, well, we want to go get a stretcher for you and take you back, send no out walk. So the medic said, well, nothing wrong with me because I couldn't walk or something was wrong. And by four o'clock at that money, we were attacked by the Korean.
We fought in Tampa 5, 6, 30 that morning. And my foot is swollen up so big as a person. And the medic said, well, we've sent you down to the ladder, check it. By the time I got to the age, the doctor said it's broken.
And they put me in a hospital airplane and a cheap then on the hospital airplane went to Japan spent four months in hospital.
I never returned to Korea. Yeah, after my four months went back to Korea on the front line. They changed the law. And all laws have always changed with me. Any time you got a broken bone, you went home except they changed the law right at that time.
Had nothing to do with me. He's just my luck with like that. I went back to Korea for another two months.
So what were your intentions upon returning to South Carolina? What hopes or plans did you have?
Well, again, when I decided to still fighting like I'm doing today, I was about 19, then 18, 19. But I was still trying to be a man. And I wanted to do some stuff to prove that I was.
So when I got the send me back to Fort Lewis, Washington, the Tacoma, and I went to administrative school. I took typing and all kinds of administrative stuff.
And I'd been company clerk and I was able to make sergeant before I got this job. I was in charge sending up people to get promoted. So I was in charge of who got the eligible put in.
I made a lot of friends came back as sergeant. I ended up making sergeant in Fort Lewis. And what I wanted to do, I felt like I could make a difference.
I wanted to be a man, not a black man. It's been years before I got the whole black thing. But I wanted to be a man. I want to prove that I was good enough. And that I could compete.
So when I came back up there on my joint with East Saw Jenkins, we talked about some of that. But some of the laws that they're trying to make today with this vote ID, it goes back to that period of time when blacks had to read a part of the Constitution to get registered to vote.
I used to teach people how to read and write those things. But a lot of the folks that we had from Johns Island, you couldn't teach them to read. But they memorized the Constitution. And they were going to take the test and pass it. And then they were conscious when they did read so well. But she memorized the whole time.
A lot of things at that point just to prove we had the Progressive Club. And where people used to East Saw Jenkins had an adult education school there. So I got to be business manager of the Progressive Club. And again, Dr. King came over and stayed with us within the 50s.
In 1959, I went to Orlando Research Center, the Orlando Folk School in Monaco, Tennessee. And they raided the place while I was there. And they arrested September clock. I mean, they really physically abused the arrested to see a guy, Kaewon was taking off the jail.
And they took that all of that property that they had there. They had said September clock. They were selling beer. Others and the charge of selling beer, the breaking the law. They had beer and sodas and crackers and stuff. And they had it out on the table. And you can get anything you want. Have you want to leave a donation you could about that. They lost all that property for that.
My bitterness continued right from the military continued to do so. And I wanted to they wanted to search all of the cars. And I refused to give them the keys and East Saw Jenkins and Ivy Quincy Newman and they were there. They came and made me give them the guys the keys.
Because I was making break open again. I get said that this nonviolent thing is not for me. I got to get out of this. And I left that 59. Back to Harlem again. But I really decided at that point, the nonviolent thing getting beat up for no reason is all not going to work for me. And I start searching there and I heard about my eyes. And then Stokely Car American. Some of these folks and I'm coming to John's Island to see me.
Got a small enough to do it. It's not really doing it. So that's all it's back on. We're okay. Okay. Have that been your first visit to Harlem? Yeah, 1959. And what what what were the certain was it?
East saw Jenkins who facilitated that or how did you get it? Yeah, he's the purpose of the visit. East saw Jenkins. Those are running charge. But what they're doing or to go to Highland that they had brought people from all over the South. Just to sit and talk to each other. And because so many of the time we thought we had the worst problem and other people had different problems.
So I'm meeting with people from Appalachia, white, poor whites and really the just strip mining and all of that stuff. You know, we got a chance to see how poor people were being treated. Not black people or Indian, but it was about poor people.
It's still like it took a while before I got all the way where I needed to go with that. But I started looking at people and started looking at our country as a class system and not a race system.
It get to be race at the bottom, but most of the time it's not racial. It's crimes. But that was your first exposure to a larger movement. Right. White and black and everybody from all over the place that was really in the miles heart and who was the director of the house. Just a brilliant guy. He was able to work through the union and everything that was changing. He was a part of change. And he used to say to us, I got a little problem on my own now what he had then.
But he said, you can't help people to do things. Then you want to tell them what to do. You got to let them do what they think is best after you have helped them to get the way they need to start from. And he did a good job on that.
So you, but already in 1959, you're beginning to question the, at least the nonviolent aspect of the mainstream civil rights movement.
Yeah, and I don't like the term nonviolent in that sense because most of us that was in that recall, you had to be violent or nonviolent. When we believed in nonviolent, we just didn't believe in people beating you up for nothing.
And that's a different, but it's never been clear for that. And I couldn't take, they came to me and you know, even doing some of this stuff and I spoke to all about turning you cheek. I only had one cheek. So I couldn't turn it.
Do you remember discussions with Esau Jenkins about this, you know, this difference in strategies?
Some, but he was really, really strong in that area. He and Dr. King all of it, they really believed it was not a fad or anything, they really believed in that.
And so I support, I did all of the work that they needed done for the nonviolent movement. I just didn't march. I just didn't do the other stuff, but the paperwork, the food, where we had it on John Downer, where I did the supportive background stuff for that.
But I couldn't go out and get beat up. We had Fannie Lou Hamer. All of these people came and stayed on John Downer. Fannie Lou, to the stories that I was just going through the other day that she was telling us a progressive club that she would be marching.
And that didn't get beat up very often because she was saying, hit my mother fuck out, kill you, hit my mother fuck out, kill you.
And so she was just walking around and doing that. And the cops would just look at it and say, that woman, they crazy, really messed up that woman.
But there was a lot of tactics that folk use not to get beat up.
What were you doing for work at the time?
I went back to high school and graduated from high school in 1956. I went to work in a mattress factory. And I made mattress for 20 years.
And I wanted, at the school when I went back to school, I took Brickland, which I wanted as a background trade, which I could do.
But I wanted a job that folk couldn't come to just find me. If I was at post office in Navy Art, I could get fired anytime for just being involved in anything racial.
Making mattresses, there was no reason to get rid of me.
And my boss, Mr. Julius Walsh, I never, again, because I was working for him and he came to me one day and said, you lazy.
And I had the sort of small attitude. And he said, I like you. And he said, because lazy people come up with an easier way to do stuff.
He said, can I start in making things? Everybody takes two people to carry mattress back to the truck. I built a thing where we put 20 mattresses on and they take it.
All of the stuff that they used to do, I changed. The owner making me forment. And the wire stuff was going on. He even put a telephone by my sewing machine.
So I had my own private telephone while doing the movement. It was a very interesting thing. And I followed that right now that lazy people really get a whole lot more done than people just don't care.
They don't just like to work, you know. If there's another way to do it, I'll find it.
But your boss tolerated your activism?
Yeah, but not just tolerated. I kept educating them about what was going on. And I used to, I've been arrested so many times, five times. I actually been in jail.
I've been in jail because the officer that I didn't dim my lights went not only like the car had was dim lights. You know, I've been in jail for mufflers.
And a lot of time my boss used to let me take the truck home because cops would be waiting for me when I get off from work that they would arrest me for certain things.
And I would go to jail. But that's the thing that start talking about writing, you know, when I did, I went into love religion and politics.
Because I knew at some point I was going to get killed by some of these people. And so I want people, my kids, exactly, to know who I was and what I'm still writing.
You began the low country news letter. And about when and why did you initiate that project?
There was a guy that's still and I think Miss Sonya and probably got some stuff on him. How would leavey? How would leavey was a captain in the army, dermatologist that refused to go to Vietnam.
And he was waiting to go to jail. He was working with some Campbell food folks, Campbell food folk in Columbia. And he was putting out a small paper up there.
And he came, we met and got him to come to John's Island. We ran into the White High School because the Black High School that they were building 1951 really had the books in the library that have anything that schools should have.
So we went into the White High School and took pictures and showed the difference between the Black High School and the White High School.
We were able to publish those things. And then when Howard was going to jail, he gave me all his stuff. And the American Friends Service was working helping me at that point.
And they were the one who had a press in North Carolina. And they gave me the press, the press of Biggest is a room of the 1890 or something or 1918, about the old old press. But we were able to use that. And that's how we were putting it.
We felt that the only way that you can really inform people is to be able to give them information. We had some folk that was close to us, a concerned citizen.
One of our members were working at the Navy Yard. And we would do the, when we first started before we had the press, we would do it just a memograph. And then he would take the memograph to the neighborhood base. And then he would run off 50, 60 copies and bring it back that we could distribute in the community.
So that's how we got before we got the press, we were putting out information.
And at this point, your target audience was mostly John S Island and Bob Malon?
Yeah, District 9, John S Island and Malon.
And that was the focus of your organizing?
Yeah, just those two artists. Those were the target for us, District and the White Hour School system, where we were the majority of those schools.
But, you know, there was so many things going on politically that we needed to, that we wanted to be a part of.
And what we did, when we decided, when he saw Jenkins, and then got appointed to that school board, we backed to that.
The leaders of Charleston came up with a scam. It is a scam that they still got in Rokin today. They decided that they were going to put together a consolidated school board.
We had eight school boards. They could get a consolidated school board and set it on top of those eight school boards.
They said they could leave those in place. But, their school board is going to be able to manage all of the money.
And they can do all of the teachers stuff. So it really took away all of the power. And then they made it at large voting.
And then a whole of Charleston County vote for those nine. And it hasn't changed. It's been 1960. It still hasn't changed.
Everybody got a vote on those members of that school board. And then in 1970, they started back having an election for these constituent boards, which began to be more and more powerless as days go.
And this had a election recently with some people that nobody ran for the board at all with vacancies.
But it's, and I still find that this is the only place in the country that you got a school system structured the way that it is.
And there's no way that anybody could ever do anything to make a difference with the Charleston County school system.
So, you know, I know that, for instance, the Millison Brown and her father with the NAACP were very active in bringing some of the desegregation cases that eventually led to the desegregation of the Charleston school.
So, I know that the NAACP was very involved in that effort. What role did you play during that time here in this larger question of school desegregation?
Well, during that time with the Millison Brown, and then that was mostly before my time in being involved in that.
But the NAACP and most of those black groups before Dr. King had an interest in just certain kids, certain colored kids going to school with whites.
It had nothing to do with the broader scope of all kids going to school.
And again, that's why Dr. King and I mean, NAACP had such a problem with Dr. King because he was for everybody, he was talking about everybody having access to a good education.
But when the Brown versus the Board of Education in Charleston, they had two schools, ICS and Avery, which were structured for the elite black kids.
And people like me had access to any of those kinds of schools. And when those schools were going out of business, that's when the integration stuff.
But it was not for me, it was for a certain group of folk in Charleston to go to those schools.
And that's why I liked the first Supreme Court decision on desegregation where people could go if they wanted to or go to school nearest to them.
Then when they changed it to integration that you had to go, that I was against busing.
The same way like George Wallace, I have my same identity people being bus 40 miles because they're integrating something.
So I made a lot of enemies with the black leaders of Charleston, they really, really hated me.
I fought against integration in 1965. I said American-eated integration, not black people.
And Americans telling people all over the world that it's doing all these beautiful things for everybody.
So we don't need to fight for that. And he saw in all of those folk that a real serious problem with me.
And they actually believed that if black kids and white kids went to the same school, they was going to learn the same way.
They'd be taught the same way. They were so wrong with that.
But again, they beat me up. I ran for the OEO Commission Board in 1967 and the black leadership of Charleston took a petition to the governor and said that not to certify me.
I won the election, but had to be certified by the governor, the black leaders with NAACP here in Charleston asked him not to certify me.
And he didn't.
This is for the Office of Economic Opportunity, the regional board.
Yeah, the local Charleston County board. And I won. And then after I refused to, they wouldn't certify me. I still went as a member.
And there was a black lady, Henry and a canti from Georgia. She eventually ran for mayor then. But she came and I told her at this meeting that I was not certified.
And she closed up a book and Charleston kind of thing was getting a million dollars in for the OEO project.
She said, when you certify him, call me. And she left. And then they came to me and said, well, you go through another election.
I said, no. When they tried some other tactics, didn't work. Then the governor said, well, I'm not going to certify anybody anymore.
So I was able to serve for that. They got even with Miss Canti too. I mean, these folks were really angry with her.
They did stuff that America does so well. They promoted her. So she would never be out in the field anymore to be in the VOLV.
She's got a good job. But that was one of those things that I really, they really saw me as a militant.
But Sylvia, I can't integrate. How could you be again integration?
So it's on the issue of non-violent self-defense, also school integration, you diverge from the mainstream civil rights leaders locally.
Yeah. See, my thing was really my own commands. And I meant to say that when we started, I think about human rights.
And I have never gotten past that. I let folks use me as civil rights. But you have to really have human rights before you can get any damn civil rights.
And most people have not gotten there yet. It was going well for a while, but it's not there anymore.
When did you first become aware of some issues taking place down at the medical college?
Again, one of those newsletters that you saw a lot ago, we've been meeting with some people down there. And we saw the condition of some of those women.
And some of the other people, some of the black men that was working there from the island. And we saw also the South Carolina in terms of the wouldn't pay minimum wage, those kinds of stuff.
So we started to look for reason to help. And when they fired, I think it was five black nurses for not doing what they knew, they was not supposed to do what they wanted to do.
They fired them. They came to me and I was able to help them get reinstated. There was a guy named Reginald Barrett. He was on the civil rights commission.
He was able to get them reinstated. And then we felt at a point that we could really, these five nurses were so good that they stood up.
There were so many people that didn't have the guts to stand up. So that's when we decided that we wanted to see if we can organize them.
And we started organizing at Mr. Barrett's house. We told the five that was fired and that we were six of them all together.
Would they bring six people? And they brought six people. Next week we asked them what y'all did to 12, bring 12. They did until we couldn't meet at his house anymore.
We started meeting at the sector, the sick off factory, the DPO hall, and we got to the point that we organized, God we had about 300 people in that organization.
And they came together for what reason? What was the pretext of their...
These meetings.
Well money, but also respect. And they had in the hospital, they had places where, you know, blacks ate the lunch in the boiler room and all of those kinds of stuff.
So they really wanted to respect, but also there were no job craftifications. You would find some place where a nurse's aide was making more than a nurse of practical license, practical nurse.
It depends on whether the supervisor likes you or not. The con... I mean they had no job description and they did those things.
So we want to make sure that all of those things was changed and that people would treat it like people.
And that was a real, real hard thing for a lot of folks to understand.
And I think that you would find that again, that group of blacks that I was talking about that had a problem with me, never got involved with this organizing.
And E. Sock Jenkins came in almost at the end of it. He did a lot of work in it coming down to the end of it and helping out.
But they didn't... they didn't see if we did not participate under those circumstances.
Because...
Most of the people called me. You know, most folks understand me. I got a lot of enemies and I keep telling people, I mean them all myself.
You know, I mean people didn't come at me. I almost all the time. When are people? When are they in a way that it caused them to be angry?
Not me. And that's... they used it as an excuse. They didn't like the tactics or any of those things.
That mostly was about me and the mill... And the other person was that we had some leaders that wanted to leave them with also black Muslim, oldest Robinson.
And he was the leader of the Muslim here. And he was really an elegant speaker and he could really do stuff with people.
The night that Dr. King got killed, I mean he talked to us for real about... because we had about 200 people in the...
And he instructed them about going home. Then other trouble he could get killed tonight because there was going to be going on.
And they did all of the stuff that we needed he did. The president of the hospital sent out a notice that he would never do anything for these people.
Because they are not important to the hospital. You know, we don't even need them. And they came back. They were so hurt and down and older stole them.
That you are somebody. Jesse Jackson took it later on. But he's... you are somebody. Although you don't operate on people and all the stuff.
But you're with the patient 24 hours a day. You clean them, you feed them, you talk to them. You're with them. You are somebody. You are somebody.
And that's how that whole thing that I am somebody came out and I noticed Robinson.
That was what it's Robinson.
That was him. He did that. He really fired up folk in terms of being proud of themselves.
The kind of job that they didn't matter that they weren't operating. That he was telling the surgeon to be with the guy.
10 minutes. You with them 24 hours a day. Now who's the most important to this person?
So that's how we got to the point where that hospital worker.
And we finally, you know, they forced the issue that we had to call in the union and SCRC came in.
But when they came in, we were. The people were organized. All they did, they started working with the people in the community.
And the piles to be. But we had the people together.
But for several months, a group of mostly black women and other low wage hospital workers as well as their community supporters had been meeting at the DPO ball.
Yeah. And you know, and people keep saying mostly women, but they were a lot of men.
They are the lives and the cooks and all of these folk were men. This thing about women being just enjoyed and did all of this stuff then started in 1980 something.
But it was a complete community effort. I got arrested with them the first night at that hospital.
So I can they put us we all were talking earlier. They put us in a cell with no windows, no, you know, just this one door.
I was in there with some guys and I'm across the four big.
You know, and I'm looking at they looking at me as the leader and I was I was really out of it.
And I had guys that was with me for two years almost started singing.
And then someone started telling jokes. And then we're just finding people start laughing and stuff.
And they came and took us out of that cell and put us in a lit of cell.
And it was one of those things that really impressed me in terms of there is something that all of us could do.
If you break your turn, there's something because I was a handicapped telling handicapped with that.
And I wanted to go back to the workers because when we had some white workers came to join the union and the black were afraid of them because they thought of them up being spies.
And we, you know, I be knew they were spies because we knew who the spies were. They were black.
And we had some covered. We were dealing with them.
But when these whites went back to work, they didn't have a job anymore.
And they never saw that anymore because the spies told who they were and what they were.
And I think when I looked at it again, it was so hard for me that I missed it.
Because those folks had special restroom. They had lunch and all of that stuff in the hospital. But they weren't making any money.
They couldn't do anything for their family that the other workers couldn't do. They were making the same money, except giving the special privilege.
And so these two groups would be dancing together.
And I started really taking a close look at the class system of our government.
At what point did SCLC enter into the picture?
Along with the union and SCLC came together. They came about in January or sometime in 69.
And this is local 1199 who came out of New York and based in New York.
They were working hand in hand in New York with SCLC, Dr. King, was involved in some of those kinds of stuff.
And they had some very powerful people. And the young guy really involved.
And again, he's a brilliant guy. We have some different opinions today about what happened with that strike.
But he did a lot of stuff.
So many of us, the folks that went to jail, he did good stuff to help people to want to go to jail.
I had a lot of young blacks.
And what I did that was so important for me that we don't visit much.
But I found so many people that were in trouble before.
That's the young black male I'm talking about right now.
So we had them as guards for the hospital workers.
And I used to have a bunch of young black male who come to me in the morning.
And I used to have a baby woman go to jail to this.
And so we would have them blinded to go to jail.
Because when they went to jail, they took over the jail.
See, they were peeping up in the jail over and over again.
So they go in as trustees, they go in whatever.
So when I was not able to go to jail, we made sure we had folk already there to protect him.
And all of the other people we had folk in jail.
And the thing that had been so good for me after that hospital strike,
all of these guys went back to school.
They're the one of them that's a minister today.
But they changed it like they needed something to hope on.
They need to be responsible or somebody to see them or somebody.
So they used to be lined up and just to go to jail.
It was a different time.
It was really a different time.
I think the hospital strike changed South Carolina.
It really did.
It brought a lot of things to human affairs commission.
But it made people feel like I am somebody.
The blacks began to get elected to public office.
No blacks were elected to public office before that hospital strike.
So it made all the difference in the world.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Tell me more about your contribution to the strike.
What role did you play?
Well, again, what I did mostly, I was a person of four came to.
With problems and stuff like that.
And what was going to go on?
And how do you solve those kind of problems?
And I would be working in the mattress factories five and a half days a week.
But I would know exactly what was going on.
You know, one other thing I did doing, I used to smoke up to that strike.
When I go to jail, I would never have any habit that I had to have.
So I haven't smoked since 1969.
But people depended on me for a lot of things.
And during the curfew, I would be one of the few people that would be out doing the curfew.
There was a vice president of the medical university that I really would like to get some recognition for at some point.
His name was William Huffitz, white guy.
And again, the final name was Poit his son on a seafood restaurant, now in Folly Road.
But him and I used to meet sometimes 12 o'clock at night doing the curfew.
And he would tell me where the hospital trustees were, what they were going on inside.
And I can tell him where I'm the young and everybody else of the union.
And how can we bring these two groups together?
And we would make proposals to each other where he would go back and say to the trustees and what I would go and say to the folks that were working with.
And we were able to do that until we got the trustees and the hospital worker leadership to meet in most corners.
Up there, away from everybody.
And they asked me to come along to ask them a question.
And the hospital worker had about 10 demands.
And what we did was, anytime they got the one that the trustees could deal with, I would let them fight over.
We just skipped that one.
And we were able to solve eight of them.
That day, and the trustees were saying to them at that point, we thought you were awful people.
And they thought the trustees were awful people.
But other folks were promoting who these two groups were not.
And if you can meet with people, you can reach them.
You don't even have to agree.
But you can reach them.
And that's how that hospital strike began to come to an end because of that meeting that we were able to put together.
So in part, you're, you play the key role in the back channel negotiations.
But you're also a trusted advisor to the workers.
And then you'd also mentioned about kind of working the street crew and coordinating those efforts.
Yeah, I see myself as a person.
I watch the them and put all of this equipment together.
But I always saw myself as a guy that set the prop, build the stage, set it, not the player, not the star.
But to be able to make sure that people can start.
And that's what I did.
I'll be able to set stages for folks to play on.
And that the good people come in and play on it.
Now, as a, as the strike became more closely identified with SCLC,
I'd imagine that officially it, you know, they were advocating nonviolent strategies.
Did you find yourself in tension with some of the SCLC leaders at that point?
Not at all.
I don't have a problem at any.
I didn't have a problem with that.
I still don't.
I had a problem with SCLC in the union on another note.
And I wanted them to send the hospital worker leaders into some training.
So they would be prepared to take over when the strike was over.
And they was refusing to do that.
They were using this mootry all over the country as a spokesman to get more unions or going all kinds of stuff.
But they were never, they were not training them to be able to run an office.
And there was no way that you can go from hospital workers to an administrative running union dues and all the other stuff that came in.
So I had a real problem with them in that area.
But not in nonviolent.
I don't have a problem with nonviolent.
I just can't do it myself.
But I didn't have a problem with that.
And for the most part, things remained peaceful in the streets of Charleston.
And then you had a heavy military presence and law enforcement and mass arrests.
Well, you know, one thing I told the FBI that they came to me quite a few times.
But they, they, that in Charleston, because they were concerned about riots and guns and stuff.
And I said, you know, we would never have a riot in Charleston.
We'll have a war.
Because we equipped a fight.
We got all equipment and everything.
And we got access down to the street and everything.
So it's not about that.
And we, you're not going to find us burning down our community or any of those things.
We just want to be treated fairly.
But weapons, handguns and stuff is not any weapon.
They are all the stuff that you use and walk.
And they understood that very much.
The head of, let's lay it out, stayed law enforcement.
He began to, matter of fact, one of the persons that we was one of the,
the people that was passing the information on was a guy that was working for the federal government.
I never learned until later on doing that time that, that,
that our, our as agent is really somebody that carry guns that can arrest people and all of that stuff.
I didn't know that until after that.
But they, you know, they, I was one of those guys.
And we were able to, to deal with that.
He left tongue and one day the, not too far from where we are.
The head of slay chief Pete Strong brought him back to Charleston.
And he was in the back of the car chief called me and said that he wanted me to meet with him with my mind.
And I told us that you got the damn power.
Anyway, you want me to be, you know, you can make me be sober.
But, what are you asking me that?
So he told me to meet him up on the motel right on, thought just a road.
He had five o'clock that evening.
And I got in my car after mattress factory downtown.
And they had police also lined up from downtown Charleston to that motel.
I could see the cars that I could go by.
And I mean, I was young.
I just wanted to tell this thing that anybody ever could do.
When I got in the parking lot where the chief for me saw his car.
I got out of my car and I ran into trunk of my car and left the trunk and just stood there.
And I mean, these guys was all over the parking lot not knowing what the hell to do.
You know, and I just looked in the trunk for good while I didn't have that plan.
And I said, and there's no reason that that didn't kill me at that particular time.
I still flashed back on that.
That was really dumb.
And I went over to the chief car and he, he didn't tell me again what he was there for.
And that, that's guy knew about it.
And that there was some plans to kill me.
And what he was there for is that he wanted to really be able to give me some protection.
And I told him that chief, please don't protect me.
Please don't do nothing to help me, you know, y'all help King and Kennedy and all of these people, y'all, please don't save me.
And at that point, we knew who was wanting to do something to me.
We already knew that there was some other white union men that had some problems with me in my pleasure.
So we were aware of that and protecting our own stuff.
But we just, so tell them we can have our own protection at that point.
You had some sort of apparatus for protecting yourself and protecting the strike leaders?
Yeah.
Yeah. And we, and our apparatus was offensive.
I, today don't believe in defense.
I don't know nothing that ever been won on defense.
Are you playing ball or anything else?
Everything is won on defense.
And what we did was that what would happen if something happened?
All kinds of stuff would happen if something happened.
And it was all, you know, it was all out there.
What, what could happen?
So we, we, and we operated that way.
We did stuff like, I have a Nazi, the worst part they had with arrest and stuff with I have a Nazi one that night,
that evening they were supposed to be ending the strike.
And we were waiting at Brooks Motel, which was the black motel that we, our office, end up being.
And the governor called me, had one of the blacks that was a part of his group to call me over there and said he wanted to talk to me, go to McNair.
And he went over and the governor said Bill, what I want you to do for me is that I want you to go to Mars Brown and Amy Church tonight.
And I want you to tell the people that we want end the strike tomorrow.
Don't worry about it. Just tell them.
And they got enough faith in you that they would believe you and everybody would go home happy.
And I said, okay, governor, let me, let me call you back.
So I went and I thought about it.
And I went back and I had to call the governor.
Now, to go to him, why don't you send me a telegram?
And I would go to the church and I would read the telegram from you that you're going to end this strike tomorrow.
And he said, Bill, let me get back to you.
He called me back about 15 minutes.
He said that he could not send me a telegram.
But he will end this strike tomorrow.
All I had to do was go and tell the people because the people got faith in nothing to do it.
I said, okay, governor, I'll do it.
And I went, Dr. Avonati was on his car leading on a car reading a Bible.
And I told him to go, Reverend, Reverend Avonati did nothing I could do.
And I got in my car and I went to John's Island.
And they arrested maybe 200 people that night from that church.
I mean, stuff just went there.
But I just went home.
Because I knew he was lying to me.
But he was setting me up that I was one that people were going to hate.
Because I was going to tell them a lie.
And that's when that strike got to where they're going to end.
And Mr. Hugh Land, who you know, a little bit about God involved to talk to somebody in the Nixon cabinet.
And they called him and asked Mr. Landson, what can we do to end this strike?
He said he's a bizz banker and it's cold business man, like my life.
He said, cut off the money.
The H.E.W. has given medical college about 75 million dollars, cut off all the money.
And tell them they can end the strike and tell people that they're doing it because they want to be good to the community.
Or tell them that they're doing it because you all made them do it.
But that's what you need to do is to cut off the money.
And then he came back to the Community Relations Committee,
which you got some papers on and said that, tell Ask Me to hold off another two weeks or so,
because he had something working.
At that point, we were working with the Long Sherman because they were about to shut down the post.
At that point also, I asked them to not do that.
And we would just wait and then they ended the strike.
But it was that thing.
And a lot of people take credit for a humiliating and a lot of folk was involved in that ending.
And one thing that is so hard for me with it, and you were talking to me earlier about my own bitterness and my hurt.
But you would find nowhere where anybody in Charleston got credit for doing anything good with that trait.
It was FCLC and the union. They did everything.
No, not the local people did anything for the lives and stuff on the night, wasn't that.
I mean, Andy Young blew up.
I mean, he got to be a Congress and all kinds of stuff.
That was a new beginning for him.
And I'm not angry about that because that's what he does best.
But some people from here needed to be credit because we the one that did the stage.
We did all the stage set in the prop.
And we the one that took all of the beating.
How did you feel about the settlement?
The settlement to me was really, really nothing.
But I think to me, we were going to make our own type of settlement in that.
And that's how come one of the things that we wondered was the Human Affairs Commission, which came out of that.
But folks are doing the only thing.
The registered voting and different stuff happening in the city of Charleston.
We end up not too long after having six Blacks on City Council.
When we had no elected Blacks on City Council, people elected the House of Representatives.
We had people elected the County Council.
And the schoolboys got elected the schoolboys.
So people have to be responsible for themselves.
All you can do set the stage for them to do it.
Now, if they don't want, I got 10 kids.
And I said, I don't want y'all to have the excuse that I had.
I didn't have access.
I'm going to give you access.
And if you don't use the damn access, that's your problem.
But I'm going to make sure you have access.
And a lot of folks are calling me.
None of my kids like me telling me 25.
I mean, I literally hate me when they call me awful father.
But, you know, I had one of my kids got in trouble graduating from high school.
He goes with two kids and they stole wine out of the grocery store and got caught.
And then my wife and other daughters, they're going to be mad at the store.
That is because they stole a wine from them.
And then they're going to say, other kids leading, Mike, I said no.
My kid had to be the leader.
He can't be my kid.
And look at other kids leading him.
He was great.
No, he's the leader.
They all hate me.
I said they really, really hate me.
My God's grace up till here.
But you have to be responsible.
You have a bad childhood I had.
I used to do with some of the young people with the bad childhood of being mistreated.
It doesn't give you an excuse to hurt people.
It doesn't give you an excuse to kill people.
A lot of folks are doing right now just because somebody did something to them.
You know, they got a right to go and hurt other people.
That doesn't give you the right to do anything.
You've still got a chance to do something.
From the hospital worker strike, you went right into the sanitation worker strike.
A lot of times gets mist.
Yeah, we had both of those things going right after that.
We had to sign a tachyns.
Some of the stuff, even some of the local hospitals sort of went on.
There were no settlements there.
And one of the reasons I'm glad you brought that back up, because one of the reasons that we had,
we went against the medical college because there was a state institution.
There were a lot of small hospitals.
But if we went against the state hospital, then we went against the whole state.
So, Amy plays that people were working for the state.
I had to sit at the door or in Greenville, South Carolina, in Columbia.
They all began to make minimum wage.
All began to have access to training program.
All of the stuff that we were fighting for benefited the whole state.
And with the sanitation department, we were able to take that over to them.
Because again, they were not being paid minimum wage.
Blacks couldn't even drive the truck sanitation.
They couldn't even ride in the front of the truck when it's raining until after that sanitation strike.
So, we were able to win that.
But again, some of my own bitterness is that I trust people.
And I trust laws that folk write.
And a lot of times, the laws are just written for a certain period of time.
And what they did, what we did, like with the sanitation worker,
they had some mean white guys that was running it.
So, what we did, and what they did is they switched them and put some mean black guys.
And so, the black guys now, I'm actually, you've been a part of that, okay?
They're mistreating the people worse than these whites ever did.
So, it's that kind of stuff that we have to come to griffin.
And again, we deal with class, the same class system.
And nobody's teaching that.
The way that these black men have treated, and not only the black men, the treating black,
but we got all these women now working in sanitation department driving trucks
and doing all kinds of stuff, and being treated awful.
And then, the racism and racism are playing in it.
And all the mistreating men that's coming from black men.
Over the last few years, I know that you've been involved in, in organizing the sanitation workers,
other city workers.
How did that all come about, is the, I guess, the re-emergence of local 1199 in Charleston?
Well, I guess, you know, folks still come back to me with some of, I guess,
being involved and stuff like that.
It is hard right now to make people responsible for themselves.
It's very hard.
And with the sanitation workers, you refine, they have so much infighting with themselves,
being mistreated, but they see themselves more as the enemy,
so they can fight among themselves and win.
And poor people are that way.
And I, right now, I sort of backed out of it for the period of time with my own mind.
Because I stopped going back over my own life, and you talk about the involvement with, like, in 1980,
I wanted to be a senator, one of my biggest ambition to be a state senator.
I club 46 people, and they were really elite groups.
And I even got some writing votes in 1968.
But in 1980, I ran for the state senator.
And I wanted the Democratic primary, and I wanted the Democratic runoff,
and we were able to do some stuff.
But again, doing that election, the NAACP opposed me.
And they brought people from Atlanta and everywhere, out on the islands,
and tell folks that they didn't want me to be elected.
And the reason that they didn't want me to be elected is because of my own family background.
They wanted a black person to be elected, the first black senator, to have a very good background from their alliance.
And they had already made their arrangement, who that person was going to be.
And so they wanted me to lose.
It was still a very, very close race.
And I think the only reason, again, I still lost that race, was because of Ronald Reagan.
And it was the first year that white people began to pull the mass to leave it.
After that point, they didn't do that.
But they wanted ID Quincy Newman to be the first black senator.
They already made a arrangement that Alexander, who you know,
these people, President Carter, Trump, was going to resign from the Senate to get a judgeship.
And they're going to have a special election for ID to be that, be that trust black senator.
So a lot of my bitterness runs very, very deep.
I'm not a one-sided thing.
My hopes with a lot of stuff, I just got sidetracked by people.
The end of the ACP opposed you in the primary and the runoff, but in the general as well?
Yeah, the general.
And they backed from a panel?
Well, they didn't back anybody. They didn't come back and McComb.
But you would find that it was back in McComb.
The Robert Ford led that thing for McComb, and then that particular point.
And they brought some confusion like they're doing with the role of the thing.
Robert put up some tickets, and they would put my name on it with a Republican.
And Trump, for example, would not, you know, just get that something.
I had so loud or something.
It's easy to mess with people that are not totally engaged.
And that's I keep hoping that we can come up with a way that we're going to be able to give people the truth.
The grandmaccano doing that run with me, he would tell people that he was going to build a coup or a bridge.
And I would say, for no freshmen senator in the status of Gailan, it could build any damn bridge.
You know, but they believed it.
And they took 25 years later before Jim Criver and Rob Nell and some of them could put that bridge together, send the homies in them.
But we love, as America, we love people that lie to us.
We love policies in the toughest lives.
And then we can fight them, say they lie later on.
But I have a lot of bitterness in terms of with my own life in terms of what I could have done.
If I had the right kind of family background and those kinds of stuff.
And you need to start off with something.
You know, being the first generation of my family to go through or to attempt to do anything.
It's not a good place to be.
Somebody asked me recently, you know, am I training anybody to take my place?
I would wish this life on the damn.
So I want nobody to live this life that I have lived.
I want to, I tell God I want to see it through.
But I, you know, I don't want to change anything.
But I don't know, I don't want to wish it on anybody.
It's been very, very hard.
And being misunderstood most of the time.
Talk people.
And most people don't know that this country was structured so well for radio.
It said that nobody could own a radio station unless serving the community, yet to serve the community before you make a nickel.
You can even gotten into TV.
So you had to, when I was doing radio, I couldn't run about five commercials.
At one time, then I had to do something for the public.
Nine days can run three hours with a commercial.
And then nobody cares.
Running Reagan again made those changes.
But we were able to really start people into radio where they really believe in what we were doing.
We had people that would take off the knob that you changed the station, the family.
You could not switch.
That nobody in the house could change the station.
Our station got the number one rating.
We had a daytime radio station.
We got the number one rating out of about 27 stations.
And Folk came at me all over the lawsuit.
Said that there was something that we were doing illegal.
And I was like, what are the reasons that they sent out?
And I've been having them bring it to church or something like that.
But what was happening at that time, with parents, black parents, I mean the kids and everybody listen to what their parents listen to in the radio.
And on Sundays, we were number one because we did gospel and talk and jazz.
So it was really something.
And I just, I loved it.
I love anything that you don't have a script.
We're getting away now from teaching.
And I'm worried about your professors and stuff.
That teaching kids to think, how do you do this without a computer?
How do you do this?
You don't have any electricity.
Those kinds of stuff.
Even the cook.
What happened if you don't have any gas or electricity?
Can you still eat?
Those kinds of things is frightening for me.
Because we are making robots out of young people.
I got some grandkids that I want to teach some stuff.
But they got all kinds of little gadgets that they're playing with.
I've watched kids riding cars with parents and never look up to see whether car coming to hit the car or any those kinds of stuff.
We really are learning our country to go in a way that scares the hell out of me.
But I don't mind having problems with enemies or anything like that.
Now we can do something.
We're dealing with the road across the island right now.
We have brought everybody that from John's Island together.
You know, ex-Clansemen and farmers and all of those.
We all together.
And what we do, I've started it myself with this concerned citizen.
We don't talk about religion and we don't talk about politics.
We just talk about the issue.
You know, if you're dealing with the issue, that's where you are.
And you don't have to worry about any of these things if you're dealing with right and wrong.
But we put all the stuff in it.
Is it right?
You know, or is it wrong?
So it doesn't matter who the hell you are.
It's a right and that's what I do.
What are you proudest?
My proudest is that I'm 76 years old and never been indicted by my government.
That was one of my biggest fears still looming over me.
But my government is the one that get rid of most people like me.
And so I've just lived this long and not been indicted.
I've even came very close a couple of times, even getting me off the public service commission.
It was one of those kinds.
I threatened indicted men and stuff.
But I am kind of proud of that.
Who taught you to organize?
Nobody.
No, no.
You know, that's one of the things I've gotten in the trouble with interviews like you before.
Because somebody has to teach you.
And the biggest teacher I've had in anything is losing.
If you continue to lose, you find ways to make it work.
And that's the thing.
I had to learn even in my elementary school to be able to work from a negative or a positive.
Because I never had a teacher that liked me from where I stood.
And then I would ask questions whether kids would not do.
So nobody taught me.
But if you know the needs, if you know the needs, you can work up a formula.
One of my teacher, my algebra teacher, really hated me with a passion.
And he gave a test one day when I came out for one day, he gave a test.
And I was able to do all of the problems.
But he still mocked my paper wrong because I didn't use the formula that the book had.
And I created my own formula in my head.
And he said it had to be that.
And I raised a lot of hell in the classroom.
And they read and got the principles.
When the principal came, and I'd say, please, just give him the problem because he's also a math.
And he did it all together differently.
And so I was vindicated at that.
And he said that it doesn't matter how you do it.
Can you check there and do you have a way to do it?
And that's the thing that's important, to be able to devise your own formula.
And one other thing I'm carrying out, I really teach, I still teach some in schools,
but that you've got to learn to enjoy the process.
Most people do not enjoy the process.
They're looking for the end results.
And that's why I ask you all the time, I start to ask him earlier, what do you want to be when you grow up?
Because if you get the point you already grown up, you don't lost it.
You've got to have some ambition to want to do something beyond what you're doing.
The process, I never have about three, four, five years of playing at the most.
But it evolves for me.
But if you satisfy what you're doing, I used to get so angry at the black teachers.
Because they look forward to getting 30 years in retirement.
Most of them die, or in an alcoholic after that time.
You've got nothing to do.
You've got to have something to do.
I work all the time, seven years a week.
But I enjoy what I do.
Even when it's hurting me, I still enjoy it, but being there to make anything right.
How could you change since coming back from Korea?
You know, again, you know the problem I got with change.
That's what I don't like to change anything.
But I like to improve upon or enhance stuff.
And I think that coming back from Korea, it lighting me, I'd like me to where I would want to be, or how I could help people.
One of the most important things that we have not talked about is gullas.
But when I got out of the mill, that gullas was such a bad word.
I hated it.
But we were able to, in 1969 or 1970, get the law passed that gullas now are language.
You know, those kinds of stuff.
Right now, we've been talking about it all.
But we have most sickle cell anemia in this area, in any place in the country.
And I started the sickle cell program back in 1970.
That we still run today.
Still run the 15, 16% for trades and stuff.
The government right now have cut 75% of our budget.
So we got people out there that are suffering.
But it is still, it's a teachable thing.
If you can test somebody to make sure that they don't have the trade.
Or if they got the trade that they don't marry somebody, that has the trade depositability of having a child.
Let's look at the cell anemia.
David Mackenna, the young man that worked for me here in the House of Revenue,
dealing with a kid of four-year-old boy last week, four years at the House of Stroke.
I haven't stroke at four years old.
And they're so much suffering out on the island and stuff.
And then the money's been cut to the bone with the education and all that stuff.
So people are suffering.
Especially in South Carolina right now, nobody in South Carolina at the top.
And the Republican Party believe in equal justice.
They don't believe in good education.
They don't want health care.
They don't want anything.
The only thing that got a problem with this immigration,
gave people, you know, and a few other little things like that.
But they just, they're interested in anything that serves people.
You know, right now they want to test welfare recipients.
We can take a drug test, you know, to get $200 a month.
We gave Boeing $700 million.
What a hell of a big welfare is you can get than that.
But again, that's why I get in trouble.
Because I deal with truth.
Are there any topics that we might have touched upon that you wanted to return to
and say a little bit more about, or maybe there's something that I didn't bring up
that kind of final wrap-up thoughts that you might have?
Well, again, I'm so concerned about the environment,
the way that the environment of being treated right at this particular point.
And I don't know the honest where I live, where we've been able to keep things pretty nice.
I mean, it's just as a war on how we develop this and the mayors and stuff like that.
And all you have to do is right now purchase three or four politicians.
And it doesn't matter. They get what they want to.
And the question that I'm hoping that even with this Smithsonian focus,
we have to find out now who democracy is working for.
I know it's not working with both of you.
Who does it work for?
Do you have to have a lot of power for democracies to work for you?
We had right now, we had five votes from county council on building a rule across the known time.
They lost five times. They're still going to have another vote.
And they're going to vote until they win.
Is that what they look for?
That would be the final vote.
And they got the people that I'm living around white and black.
They say, they're going to do what they want to do.
And American people can't do that.
We can't say that, well, though we know we're right, they're going to do what they want to do.
And that's where our history is so important for American history.
The focus to go against those green and make it work.
They didn't give up on it.
But the political leaders that have really been poor.
And we got four or five of them that focused just getting to do what they want,
the developers are telling them what to do.
And that's what they do.
Even on John's Island right now where they got the developers are going into the high school,
and into the churches and giving $1,000 in $1,000 to this kid.
And they're taking over the organization that used to help people so they put money into it.
And everybody saying, grab grateful for this money.
I am through.
But it's a better thing.
And I can tell you, the only person I'm getting along with the developers meet.
I'm not getting along with anybody but me.
I drink some cherry wine and I write.
And I think, and I pray a lot.
I do believe in God.
I know by God's grace I've been able to get to this point in history.
But it scares me for my country.
We got leadership right now in the state of South Carolina all over the country.
But especially in the state of South Carolina.
We're like totally like a leadership.
And I'm leading the one that, you know, and it's such a difference between a leader and a manager.
And taking managers and calling them leaders.
I am through.
Well, thank you very much for sitting down with us today.
You're welcome.
I'm very happy to be well appreciated by the group present.
And I think many, many more people will benefit from your reflection.
We got to do something about tomorrow.
We've sort of lost yesterday and today.
But we got to do something about tomorrow.
Because we don't, we all are going to be lost.
It's a generation, two, three generation below.
It's tomorrow.
Great.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.